Okay.
This next story is simultaneously major breaking
news and completely
obvious and unsurprising to anybody who's
been paying attention.
Yesterday, Lieutenant Colonel Alexander Veneman
testified before Trump impeachment investigators.
Then men is this national security counsel,
top Ukraine expert that has been embroiled
in the Ukraine fiasco of Donald Trump and
that July 25 phone call and he testified that
references to Joe Biden were removed proactively
from the so-called transcript of that phone
call between Donald Trump and the Ukrainian
president.
Zelenskyi.
This is a major claim.
This is a massive, this is massively important
on a substantive level, but it is also exactly
what any sensible person thought was going
on from the second Trump said they were going
to be releasing a transcript.
Trump called it a word for word transcript,
but what the white house released from the
July 25 phone call was a sampling of things
that were reportedly said.
Remember it was a 30 minute phone call.
There were about six or seven minutes of conversation
that were included in what the Trump white
house released.
Even if you assume that that was doubled in
how much time it took up because of live translation
back and forth for Trump and Zelenskyi.
There is still obviously a lot missing from
that phone call.
We knew this the second we looked at the so-called
transcript and now Lieutenant Colonel Veneman
says, this is what went down.
Veneman says he tried to change the transcript
to include Trump telling Zelenskyi that there
are Biden tapes, for example, that was allegedly
one of those mysterious ellipses that I pointed
in a pointed out in the transcript, which
we believe represent removed parts of the
conversation.
The white house claims.
Now those ellipses don't mean that, um, of
course it was not added in as we know, despite
Veneman his insistence Veneman wanted the
transcript edited to show that Barisma was
mentioned.
The company that hired Hunter Biden, uh, he
claims it was mentioned during the call.
No, can do not putting that in the transcript.
We're releasing either.
So let's be clear.
Is this the smoking gun?
It's not.
And you have Democrats and Republicans and
Veneman all saying, listen, the general tenor
of the, uh, transcript, which was really a
summary is mostly accurate.
But the important point is when the subject
is what was said about Joe Biden and Hunter
Biden.
And there are allegations that are referenced
to Joe to two Biden and a reference to the
company Hunter Biden was working for were
removed.
It is one of many red flags in this entire
thing.
It's also another analogy to the impeachment
inquiry against president Richard Nixon during
the 1970s, which ultimately led to his resignation.
Harvard law professor Lawrence tribe mentioned
the Nixon tapes and Nixon's effort to hide
the most incriminating parts of those tapes.
And you may know this, you may recall if you
were around at the time or you may have read
about it, there was a very, uh, controversial
18 and a half minute gap that was found in
one of the Nixon tapes.
Eventually, Nixon's personal secretary, uh,
took responsibility for that missing part,
saying she accidentally deleted it.
And that was not a claim that everybody believed
to put it lightly, the Trump ellipses or the
truncation of the transcript that may end
up being equivalent to Richard Nixon's missing
18 and a half minutes and it is yet another
small way in which this is looking more and
more like Richard Nixon's early 1970s with
every passing day.
Is anybody really shocked that Trump may have
committed crimes or obstruction to cover up
crimes or obstruction.
And once again, we find ourselves pulling
out Occam's razor outcomes raiser more really
meant to be applied to scientific assertions
than the political or cultural.
But I think it still applies.
Either Trump is lying to cover up corruption.
Okay.
Or we have a purple heart military veteran
who happens to be a Ukrainian double agent
spy who's involved in one of the most incredible
cover-ups ever to cover up the fact that he
is actually a spy and is making false claims
under oath about what he saw in relation to
that July 25 phone call.
Hard to say, which is more likely, Oh well,
Trump constantly tries to cover up his wrongdoing
and distract or suppress it, so I know for
me, which is the most likely scenario, unfortunately
seems like for many Trumpists, they're having
a hard time figuring out which is most likely
outcomes.
Razors seems to have been completely thrown
out the window as a concept for Trumpists
as part of their package of weaponized ignorance
and cognitive dissonance that has become basically
their operational status quo in the Trump
era.